[Music]
we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to [ __ ] boots
you are down to your last life
you need to retire
[Music]
grab the cats sister kitties meet your
new roommates well
I supposed to be a furious hero a legend
spread this is a person party that's
your party so this is where dignity Goes
To Die the year start coming and they
don't stop coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
no hablo English
I don't speak Spanish either
you're funny uh what's your story my
story
what are we looking at cats have nine
lives what what
I think you said they have been too high
no I am on my last life oh no
Legend tell us
waiting to be grounded
I need your help is the great pools in
Boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish you get me my
lives back okay okay pause on face I
won't make you back but first
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
[Music]
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
you will find your reward does not come
easily Puss in Boots Goldie bears
[Music]
when you only have one life that's what
makes it special go get him tiger hey
take it easy
[Music]
it's gonna be fun
[Music]
I am
good
in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out
okay
[Music]
thank you